ALMOST CAME ON TO THE ICE.CTION
QUICKLY REALIZEG, RIGHT BACK ONO
THE BENCH AGAIN.
NIFTY LITTLE MOVE IN TIGHT BY
PETTERSSON.
KICKS IT TO THE S
>> Harnaryan: NOW, FOR THE BACK.
AND MIKE SMITH, LARCECE WILL SH.
HE CAN'T SHOOT IN THE SHOOTOUT,
THAT WAS MY MISTAKE, SINGER.
OAL!
>> Louie: WHAT A FIST PUMP.
E PENGUINS THE OTHER WAY
HAVE A BREAKAWAY.
RODRIGUES IS IN ON LINE CHANGES
GETTING GUYS EXHAUSTED.
DOUP.
HUGHES -- BACK HANDS.
WE ALL KNOW WHAT PATRICK KANE
HAS DONE IN HIS CAREER. TWO-GOA,
BUT IN THE SHOOTOUT, NINE IN HOE
THEM.
RUOTSALAINEN IS COMING IN FOR
THEE IN.
>> YEAH, ON THE BACKHANDAY TO
THE NET.
AND JUST SHOT IT WIDE! IN FRONTS
AND SAVE AND THE REBOUND WENT
WIDE!
OH, IS THIS WILD?SHOT!
AND THEN WE HAD THESE
GOALTENDERS COM
AWAY.
HOW ABOUT THOSE SAVES COMINANOT.
SHESTERKIN GETS BACK. A FINISH!
>> Joe: THEY HAD TO WIN A HOW .
WHAT AEFENDER TWO ON ONE,
FAKSAA
TO IT CLEANED IT.
HE WAS
THE BACK HAND UP TALBOT, AND
BACK COME THE WILD, THREE ON ONE
AT THE JETS LINE.ONE, LOWRY TO
AND
REBOUND SENT OVERTOP OF THE NET.
ANSO FAR. CAN SKATE AND A TREME
SKILLED PLAY HERE TO GET THIS
PUCK ON HIS BACKHAND AND GET A .
GIVE TO ZACHA.
SHOOTING,UND DEFENSE.
WEAVING HIS WAY IN.L MOVE.
>> IT'S BEEN A NATE FOR
NATHAN MACKINNON. TO BEAT HIM OE
PAD.
SHOWING ANYTHING.
IT'S A
GAME OF CHICKEN.
THE GOALIE
WINS IT FOR THE AVALANCHE IN A
HAGEL TAKES IT AWAY, YOU KNOW W,
FOROVE BY WILLIAM
NYLANDER.
PUPUY SCORE!
OVERTIME  GET A STICK UNDERNEAT
HIM.
HETHE EER.
HERE HE COMES LOOKING TO END
THIS ONE AND L THE POST.
>> GREAT SAVE BY ROBIN GOING.
HERE COMES ROY TO THE NET.
A LITTLE LEG KICK AS HE COMES
IN.
DUCHENE, BACK DOOR.
RYAN PULOCK O RIGHTHIS